[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos si existe algo
característico del extremo este de asia
eso ha sido últimamente la lucha de
poder entre diferentes actores políticos
y militares como son china rusia eeuu y
desde luego se ha existido un país una
nación un pueblo que siempre ha estado
en medio de tantas turbulencias
geopolíticas ya fuese en los tiempos de
predominio de la unión soviética o de la
china moderna ese no ha sido otro que
korea
el pueblo de corea que históricamente se
ha visto forzado a sobrevivir entre las
influencias del imperio chino y las
aspiraciones expansionistas del imperio
japonés se encuentra dividido en dos
países ideológicamente opuestos cada uno
de los cuales es apoyado por una
superpotencia entre las que además
existe mucha tensión y una enorme
desconfianza todo esto ha propiciado que
estos dos países hayan situado a sus
fuerzas armadas como toda una prioridad
nacional a día de hoy como todos sabéis
corea del norte posee armas nucleares y
una tecnología relativamente avanzada en
misiles balísticos así como miles y
miles de piezas de artillería por su
parte corea del sur posee uno de los
ejércitos mejor equipados
tecnológicamente de todo el planeta con
una fuerza aérea muy avanzada y uno de
los sistemas de protección antimisiles
más punteros que existen
[Música]
sin embargo a pesar de que ambas coreas
están armados hasta los dientes lo
cierto es que a día de hoy un nuevo
enfrentamiento armado entre ambas parece
algo poco probable y al contrario de lo
que ha ocurrido en otros casos en los
que la calma se ha logrado gracias a la
vía diplomática en korea la tensa paz
que se vive hoy en día es el resultado
casi en exclusiva de la disuasión
militar ni las cumbres de tranvía kim
jong-un en singapur y hanoi ni los
encuentros entre múnich y men panmunjom
y pyongyang han servido para mejorar
sustancialmente las cosas en korea la
vía diplomática está simple y llanamente
congelada hablamos de un escenario en el
que los dos actores especialmente uno de
ellos con la del norte son incapaces de
ceder una pizca de terreno político
diplomático o militar al contrario el
hecho es que eeuu no encuentra la manera
para que pyongyang se deshaga de sus
armas nucleares y claro con el norte no
puede permitirse abandonar el armamento
nuclear porque de él depende la
supervivencia del propio régimen y luego
a pesar de esos múltiple
corea del sur ha sido incapaz de
promover reformas en el norte que
permitan levantar las sanciones y poder
cooperar económicamente así que que
queda en medio de semejante berenjenal
exacto la disuasión militar esto es ser
lo suficientemente fuerte como para que
al contrario no se le pase ni
remotamente por la cabeza utilizar la
vía de las armas para conseguir sus
objetivos y amigos eso es precisamente
lo que vamos a ver en este vídeo pero no
esta vez nos vamos a hablar del ejército
norcoreano estoy seguro de que ya
habréis oído mil y una cosa sobre él así
que en esta ocasión os vamos a hablar
del mucho más desconocido ejército
surcoreano según diferentes estimaciones
el sexto ejército más poderoso del mundo
atentos
[Música]
el escudo americano amigos amigas de
visual político
la evolución del ejército surcoreano ha
sido casi tan exitosa como el propio
milagro económico del país en apenas
unas décadas pasó de ser poco más que el
ejército de pancho villa' a convertirse
en uno de los más avanzados del mundo
como os podéis imaginar no recorrieron
este camino solos en este caso los eeuu
jugaron un papel fundamental
[Música]
es el fin de la guerra de corea en 1953
la defensa de corea del sur quedó
técnicamente en manos de los eeuu quien
comandaba elop com el acrónimo de
control operacional durante la guerra
los surcoreanos habían gastado todos sus
recursos militares el agotamiento junto
a la escasez de equipamiento moderno
imposibilitaba una retirada total de la
potencia norteamericana
en ese caso había dejado al país
completamente desprotegido y al amparo
de sus vecinos comunistas china y corea
del norte así que lo que hicieron fue
quedarse y entrenar construir y preparar
al ejército surcoreano de hecho buena
parte del diseño de las estructuras
militares surcoreanas se hizo replicando
cuando menos inspirándose claramente en
el modelo de las fuerzas armadas
norteamericanas
y no sólo eso además para compensar la
escalada armamentística norcoreana eeuu
desplegó en corea del sur algunas de sus
armas estratégicas más importantes
incluyendo las temidas armas nucleares
a finales de los 50 estados unidos
comenzó a trasladar a korea numerosas
cabezas nucleares llegaron a sumar casi
1000 unidades a mediados de los años 60
sin embargo a medida que la guerra fría
se iba apagando por un lado y por otro
las relaciones entre washington y pekín
no paraban de mejorar este poderoso
arsenal nuclear fue reduciéndose poco a
poco de tal forma que para 1991 ya no
quedaban cabezas nucleares
norteamericanas desplegadas de forma
permanente en corea del sur y
exactamente lo mismo ocurrió con el
despliegue de tropas norteamericanas que
poco a poco fueron reduciéndose pero
claro todos esos años en los que decorar
el sur quedó completamente bajo el
paraguas militar norteamericano le
dieron al país tiempo para mejorar sus
capacidades militares por ejemplo el
propio presidente pax jong-il puso en
marcha en la década de los 70 un
ambicioso programa conocido como un box
para impulsar una industria militar
autóctona pero no sólo era una cuestión
de cantidad de armas si realmente
querían ser autosuficientes en el
terreno militar y garantizar la
seguridad nacional con
dependencia de las decisiones que se
tomarán en washington los surcoreanos
necesitaban equipos punteros capacidades
de intervención rápida y nuevas
estructuras adaptadas a los requisitos
de la guerra moderna y eso eso es
precisamente lo que hicieron atentos
[Música]
un cambio de rumbo
el gran reto al que se ha enfrentado el
ejército surcoreano durante los últimos
40 años ha sido pasar de ser una fuerza
prácticamente terrestre a una mucho más
equilibrada en la defensa del aire y el
mar para este objetivo se pusieron en
marcha tres reformas militares una en
2005 y otra en el 2011 y la última en
2017 por parte del actual presidente
multi y con estas reformas el objetivo
ha sido reducir sustancialmente el
tamaño del ejército pero convirtiéndolo
al mismo tiempo en una fuerza mucho más
temible con mejor equipamiento mejor
entrenada una mayor capacidad de
despliegue y que esté formado por
mejores unidades de tierra mar y aire
consiguiendo así una relación total de
[Música]
eso sí a pesar de que muchas de estas
reformas han llevado a cabo o se han
implementado en gran medida el op com
quien tendría el control militar en
tiempos de guerra no ha sido transferido
sigue estando bajo dirección de los eeuu
y de hecho la última de las tres
reformas militares la del actual
presidente mundo llamada de r 2.0 está
orientada a mejorar las capacidades
contra la guerra asimétrica norcoreana y
también a conseguir por fin el traspaso
a corea del sur de lop con en tiempos de
guerra pero bien el caso es que hasta
ahora los refuerzos se han centrado
sobre todo en completar el desarrollo de
tres estrategias clave contra las
amenazas norcoreanas actuales el sistema
preventivo kilstein la defensa aérea y
de misiles de corea y el castigo masivo
y represalias de corea las tres por
cierto son estrategias de combate
orientadas a la difusión y ojo porque es
algo que los surcoreanos se están
tomando muy pero que muy en serio sin ir
más lejos la intención del presidente
mundo es lograr que entre los años 2017
y 2023 el gasto militar crezca a un 53
por ciento pasando así de un presupuesto
de en torno a los 30 mil millones de
dólares anuales
otro que supere los 50 mil millones
ahora bien exactamente qué implican en
términos de armamento todos estos
cambios pues bien veamos los
[Música]
las joyas de la corona
si hablamos de equipamiento militar
podemos decir que corea del sur tiene o
está comprando algunos de los mejores
equipamientos militares del mundo y no
sólo hablamos de equipamiento digamos
tradicional además de los
aproximadamente 2 mil 500 tanques 2.400
vehículos blindados las 5400 piezas de
artillería a los más de 150 cazas
modernos que forman el inventario de
guerra surcoreano tenemos que añadir
también un avanzado equipamiento en
defensa antimisiles y disuasión
balística y también durante los últimos
años el país ha estado negociando la
adquisición de cazas de quinta
generación
[Música]
estamos hablando por ejemplo de los
estadounidenses f-35 estel fighter de
los cuales corea del sur contará con 80
60 de la versión ai 20 del ave una
versión con capacidad de despegue
vertical además la empresa aeroespacial
autóctona que está desarrollando
paralelamente un caza también de quinta
generación muy parecido al f-35
denominado por el momento como kfx la
intención de este programa es que las
capacidades de este avión superen
ampliamente por ejemplo las del
eurofighter europeo huelgas son rafael
francés
pero no solo hay novedades en el aire la
marina surcoreana está inmersa en un
programa de construcción y adquisición
de nuevos submarinos que incluye el
desarrollo de una nueva clase autóctona
los submarinos de la clase
ian bogost 3 asimismo también está
incorporando destructores equipados con
el sistema de combate aegis y
portaaviones ligeros desde los cuales
podrá operar el f-35 pero sin duda los
avances militares más importantes se
están produciendo en el terreno de la
defensa antimisiles corea del sur ya
tiene desplegado un paraguas antimisiles
de bajo nivel mediante baterías patriot
que conforman un sistema pack 2 un
sistema que por cierto corea del sur
está ya a punto de mejorar a pack 3 para
conseguir que sea mucho más preciso y
tenga una mejor respuesta ante ataques
con misiles de corto y medio alcance el
pack 3 utiliza un motor de cohete de
combustible sólido de 2 púlsares que
aumenta la altitud y el alcance para
defenderse de las amenazas en curso por
lo que se espera que los nuevos
interceptores de misiles sean útiles
para frustrar el nuevo tipo de amenazas
de misiles del norte funcionario anónimo
del ministerio
defensa de corea del sur y no sólo eso
también está desplegado otro escudo
anti-misiles de alto nivel el famoso y
polémico chat estadounidense que tiene
como objetivo proteger al país de
misiles intercontinentales o de grandes
dimensiones que vuelan a mucha mayor
altura pero sin duda lo más llamativo es
el esfuerzo de corea del sur por
independizarse y crear un tercer escudo
anti-misiles esta vez autóctono hablamos
del tormes
2 este sistema utiliza la tecnología
rusa de interceptación de su famosísimo
s400 un momento tecnología rusa en corea
del sur y eeuu se niega a vender ese
tipo de tecnologías a terceros países
aunque se trate de aliados tan
importantes como es el caso de corea del
sur así que los surcoreanos han tenido
que recurrir a los rusos los misiles de
este sistema están siendo desarrollados
por la empresa surcoreana league
next 1 y a pesar de tener un coste
unitario de 1,2 millones de dólares lo
cierto es que el sistema surcoreano cho
m2 tiene el objetivo de convertirse en
uno
de los escudos antimisiles más baratos
del mundo está previsto incluso
exportarlo a otros países del sudeste
asiático y aunque no ofrece el mismo
rango que otros sistemas antimisiles la
idea de las autoridades surcoreanas es
aprovechar su bajo coste para
desplegarlo por todo el país creando así
una verdadera cúpula de hierro el
sistema es capaz de interceptar misiles
hasta 15 kilómetros de altura y 40
kilómetros la redonda de donde está
situada la batería
el caso es que de esta forma con la del
sur contará previsiblemente a partir del
próximo 2021 no con uno ni dos sino con
tres sistemas antimisiles que protegerán
al país de la amenaza norcoreana sin
embargo muchos se preguntan es todo esto
suficiente pues bien ahí está el debate
y lo cierto es que no existe consenso
muchos expertos militares e incluso ex
ministros surcoreanos han llegado a
pedir ir más allá y desarrollar de una
vez por todas armas nucleares propias
ahora bien es razonable que corea del
sur desarrolló sus propias armas
nucleares es posible desde el punto de
vista militar y desde el político y
diplomático bien atentos
[Música]
una solución nuclear
puede que a muchos no os suena de nada
pero el programa nuclear de corea del
sur no es algo descabellado ni siquiera
algo que no se haya intentado ya de
hecho a principios de los 70 y a pesar
de que ya había cabezas nucleares
estadounidenses en corea el presidente
pactó y lanzó un programa autóctono de
desarrollo de armas nucleares el
programa sin embargo se quedó en la fase
de investigación y aunque se cree que
corea del sur logró los conocimientos
necesarios como para fabricar un arma
nuclear lo cierto es que nunca se
produjo ni se probó ningún artefacto
pero porque se detuvo el programa
[Música]
pues fue simple y llanamente por la
presión de eeuu que se mostró desde un
principio en contra de esta
proliferación nuclear en corea y al
final consiguió disuadir a pac para que
lo paralizará y firmara el tratado de
no-proliferación en 1975 sin embargo
muchos analistas creen que corea del sur
realizó algún que otro experimento
durante los siguientes años a escondidas
y que hoy sería capaz de construir una
bomba nuclear en no más de 18 meses eso
le convertiría de hecho en un estado
nuclear de facto estatus que compartiría
por ejemplo con países como japón
[Música]
y claro durante los últimos años sobre
todo tras las últimas pruebas nucleares
norcoreanas del 2016 y 2017 han sido
numerosas las voces en korea que han
clamado por retomar el programa
autóctono de armas nucleares de hecho
según una encuesta realizada en
septiembre de 2017 por gallup el 60% de
los surcoreanos estarían de acuerdo con
desarrollar sus propias armas nucleares
el 60%
además las facciones más nacionalistas y
conservadoras de cora del sur creen que
no se puede seguir dependiendo de eeuu a
la defensa estratégica ya que si algo ha
demostrado la presencia de donald trump
es que eres capaz de defender tu o lo
vas a pasar realmente mal
y es que a diferencia de otros
presidentes trump ha sido con diferencia
el que ha tenido un trato menos amistoso
con quien puede que sea su mejor aliado
en asia oriental frank revive la disputa
del reparto de costes con corea del sur
perdemos 4.500 millones de dólares
defendiendo un país que es
condenadamente rico y al que
probablemente no les gustemos mucho
presidente trump si lo habéis escuchado
bien trump desató toda la disputa
diplomática con corea del sur para que
el país pagase más dinero a eeuu con los
costes de las tropas estacionadas allí y
de hecho trump consiguió sacar al
presidente de munt mil millones de
dólares más algo de lo que llegó incluso
a mofarse descaradamente ha sido más
fácil sacarle mil millones de dólares a
los surcoreanos que conseguir 114 con 13
millones de un apartamento de renta
regular en brooklyn presidente trump y
haber pues claro es lógico que ante la
hostilidad hacia corea del sur
demostrada por trump durante su
presidencia muchos se pregunten si fuera
del sur con los medios militares y
económicos que tiene debe seguir acaso
dependiendo de los yankees para su
defensa estratégica por este motivo las
armas nucleares han vuelto al centro del
debate
que el presidente mundial dicho que
durante su presidencia esto no sucederá
aún así vosotros qué pensáis debería
acordar el sur garantizar su capacidad
de disuasión nuclear ante la amenaza
norcoreana y los últimos desplantes de
eeuu al fin y al cabo ahora del norte ya
las tiene y tiene cero intenciones en
deshacerse de ellas así que por qué no
cora del sur
no sería acaso más práctico desarrollar
armas nucleares propias en lugar de
tener a casi 25.000 soldados
estadounidenses generando unos elevados
costes para ambos países o quizás por
contra esto supondría un problema
diplomático y alimentaría el conflicto
con corea del norte en fin desde luego
no son preguntas nada sencillas de
responder pero así están las cosas en la
península de corea déjanos tu opinión en
los comentarios y recuerda si este vídeo
te ha gustado
no olvides darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a nuestro canal avisar
política y no perderte nada nuevo una
vez más gracias por estar ahí un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]